[Music]
what me to jail
directions to Belvoir Valley Farm and
the new owner infimum ear correct I
think there's an intriguing backstory to
your arrival
well after losing my job and my
boyfriend in San Francisco I answered a
win and in contest you wanted in okay to
go to New Zealand so I 13-hour flight
Auckland and three bus ride later I'm so
sorry I will pay for any of the damages
well this did put a big dent in my
vehicle haha I'm officially the owner of
an imp never assume anything when the
Internet matches this profile picture
you've seen a ghost
built Gilbert he's a wily fella do you
know anybody in town that does
renovation strike the tailor can I have
his phone number
Jake what's your phone number who's
asking figures no I didn't what are you
on my number I was hoping to talk to you
about a proposition
she's a real beauty I can help you
you're still a hitter original glory
brilliant you see broken what's with you
in the old houses Oh we'll always took
the building makes me feel a little
worse I believe agent Alice most
eligible bachelor might be keen on you
she's a beaut she sure is
yes guess what I got a brand new job for
you
I do have my realize to get back to real
life
seems to me you haven't told her how you
actually feel
and give some universe has its own
planes two things I like to imagine very
timing
so we're all friends -
[Music]